I was born in Vancouver Washington
I had
a very good father a very good mother a
brother and sister my father owned a
small Millwork company my mother was
wonderful as they say housemaker
she was also a frustrated artist
what is unique about us I believe and
has a lot to do with the way in which
I've lived my life is that
I went to public schools with my brother
and sister we were seen by much of the
world as very normal people except we
were also Plymouth Brethren
Plymouth Brethren would be we were
separatists we were everybody in my in
Mars in our assembly
we never used the word church
were pacifists except my father in World
War II
um
the most important thing about that is
and it becomes very much a part of this
whole story is that I was always felt
separate from everyone else even though
I certainly was welcomed by everybody
and we always fit in
to the degree that we allowed ourselves
to fit in in school
um my father I discovered when I was a
boy going through a chest of his in in
the in the Attic of where in the smaller
house that we grew up in
it was a runner and I found his medals
and part of me said I want to be like my
father like every boy in America
everywhere probably
and so I became a good runner in high
school and I set a National High School
record which sent me out into the world
and I had many scholage college
scholarships
um
and at the same time we grew up my
father did well in his business we had
horses
um
but I also learned we also had a very
good we had a very good Outdoors
Northwest life but my father also said
a man only needs one match to light a
fire he taught me how to shoot a rifle
and how to break it down
when I was probably eight or nine years
old at the same time we were very
religious he wanted me to go to West
Point but he also wanted me to be a
missionary so I'm caught between these
two worlds as a Young Man
in college I I had I had success as a
runner but at the same time I didn't I I
um discovered girls went out uh
drank alcohol all of this worked against
me I didn't get along with my coach
and ultimately I left I was at the
University of Oregon which is the main
track and field school in America at
that time I think it probably still is
it was the most important thing in my
life that was more important to me than
than
studying although I felt I did study
hard as a result of the problems I had
with my coach I felt that I had not
reached the the level as an athlete that
I could even though I was
a Pan-American team and
seventh ranked 800 meter runner in the
world
I felt in some ways that I had failed
and after college
um I did not make the Olympic team that
year when I thought I could in many ways
I felt I should have I
went to my father and I said I'm leaving
the country I'm going to hitchhike I'm
going to hitchhike through Europe my
mother cried my father gave me a camera
and I made my way
hitchhiking like so many Americans do
through Europe
and I went down made my way through
France and then down through Spain
and I reached the reached the
Mediterranean
and I looked across
the Border or the the Mediterranean
and I said I'm not finished yet there's
something on the other side where I have
to go
and for the first time I began to feel
there's something inside of me searching
for what we will call the wild
I took a small small boat lying low in
the water with about
three or four other people reached
reached Tangier
X number of hours later I don't know how
long it took and the next day I heard
for the first time the Muslim called a
prayer
and what is this what does it mean
and it drew me in
and I felt I had to hitchhike across
North Africa at the same time as I was
standing on the road with a fire in the
barrel on this highway that took you
across North Africa uh with which where
I was told which is where I should go to
hitchhike across where there were a lot
of truck drivers would would meet in the
morning and when fire was burning in the
barrel and I heard the call of prayer
again somewhere in the desert and I
wanted to go down there there was
something about growing up in a very
religious environment feeling that I had
failed the god of my youth
and that when I reached when I was in
Tangier the god of my youth was calling
me there was something there was
something deeply religious always within
me it was bred into me as a boy as as as
water makes a flower grow just it was it
was the nourishment of our youth that we
were separate from everyone else we were
deeply religious as well as being
completely a part of the world but that
became so much a part of me and becomes
a very much a part of my life
and as I hitchhiked across
North Africa
it was during Ramadan when Muslims don't
don't eat during the day from Sun from
sunrise to sunset I heard men say
inshallah and I didn't know what that
meant was but it said God willing and I
said that's just how we talked in church
when I was a boy I kept going
finally
uh
thought I would make my way towards the
Holy Land
and find a new God there
but I got as I made my way across I
I decided to hitchhike well I was
hitchhiking and I got to uh
Algiers from Algiers I made my way to
Tunisia and from Tunis I decided instead
to take a boat across the night and I
remember at night I ran to it was a boat
one boat was leaving uh once a week to
Sicily I ran or jumped over there or
climbed over a fence jumped on the boat
as it made its way to as as it was
leaving the harbor the next day we
arrived in palmeiro Sicily and I
hitchhiked up
to through Italy and down into
Yugoslavian across to Turkey and it was
in Turkey where I got a letter from my
father at Post Restaurant which said
Post restaurant at that time this is all
pre-digit the digital world was uh in in
any at that time in any uh post office
in any major city in Europe perhaps here
and you can do the same thing in America
you would just write you know Jerry Van
Dyke Post Restaurant Istanbul and the
letter would get to you and there was a
letter from my father you've been
drafted you have to come home
my father was in the Marine Corps in
World War II I could not say no to my
father
and at the same time it was during the
war and I haven't gone into this yet but
Vietnam I
various mixed emotions about it didn't
want to ever disappoint my father at the
same time I certainly didn't support the
war
on I was I was in in um in the in the um
what we call I forget what we call now
um
youth hostel in Istanbul
and I was sitting in my bunk and I
had maps in front of me and I was
planning my trip up through them with
Eastern Europe part of the Soviet Bloc
during the time of the Cold War where I
would go and then I would take make my
way to Luxembourg where I had a to buy
an airline ticket where I hadn't already
I had flown over on that on on air
Luxembourg which was the cheapest way to
go to Europe then and make my way back
and go home and into the army and that
time men and women boys and girls were
kept separate in all youth hostels so
incomes I'm sitting there planning my
trip back and this woman comes in and
she says hi leather Crete and boots and
she had a beautiful scarf on and she had
this leather coat which is the type that
you could buy in Istanbul then that were
very popular with hitchhikers and she
said where's Lacey and she wasn't
supposed to be in there where there were
the men or boys were and he turned over
in his bunk and said I'm lazy and she
said I saw your sign downstairs looking
for writers to go to Asia I want to go
with you
and she he said we'll be downstairs at
eight o'clock the next following morning
and I she left
and I looked over the over to him and I
said do you have any more room and he
said yeah he said be downstairs at eight
o'clock in the morning it was because of
that woman and so we left her about six
of us we took out the back seat of a
Volkswagen and we made our way
across turkey and as we were traveling
across I really I saw soldiers working
uh trying to clear snow from the roads
and I said oh the military can be a
force for good in the world and I
appreciate it and I saw a lot of poverty
on that trip when America could could
could
could do and I and had done for me and I
finally we got as we were um as we were
and so as we were traveling across I
became closer to this woman and as he
said well Lacey who was going a he was
AWOL from the Navy he was going to India
to make try to earn money or make money
with with by buying uh buying gems and
coming back to Europe and selling them
he said well trip will be easy we make
our way across turkey
Iran is easy
Afghanistan Afghanistan's a little
that's a little different like
Afghanistan it's different oh there's
something that clicked inside of me
at the turkey at the Turkish Iranian
border I knew I had to turn around and
go home and I went home and went into
the army
but I held on to that belief there's
something something romantic something
exciting something different from
Afghanistan from the rest of the world
so I was I was in the I was in the Army
for two years and I got out and I went
to graduate on the GI bill I went to
graduate school in Paris very serious
about
academics and I was still running and
I became more successful as as an
athlete made the U.S national team and
carried the American flag in the closing
ceremonies the U.S Russia track meet
during the height of the Cold War which
was the second most important track made
besides the Olympics during that time
even more important because of the
politically
um and but I was
so I finished I was running hard
at the same time I also
had not forgotten Afghanistan finishing
the last day of school in Paris I saw my
name on the wall posted outside that I
had passed my classes I was very happy I
went and I joined about a half a dozen
friends of mine from different countries
we sat in a cafe
uh it was at the Institute of political
studies was just down the street from
this from from The Institute and we went
around as young men do the table what
were we going to do next in life well
this person was going to be a banker
this person was going to be a journalist
this person was going to I mean you
wouldn't be an art historian and I said
I want to go to Afghanistan
just like that out of the blue it came
up
so what I did was I was still running a
bit I went to Northern Europe to earn
money on the international track and
field uh circuit and I came back and I
called my parents and I said I'd like
Cody my younger brother was just
finishing High School to join me I
wanted to drive a car across Asia I want
to go to Afghanistan and to this day my
brother and I do not know why our mother
said yes my father's my father also gave
his approval and at that time
you could buy an old Volkswagen or even
a Mercedes in Europe and young people
were doing this and a lot of older older
people were also and you could drive it
across Asia and sell it for a profit and
use that money to fly back home and even
have money left over and so I bought an
old Volkswagen my brother came flew over
we met we actually met in Germany
and we began to travel on what I had
started to travel on by going to in in
Istanbul which is what today is called
in retrospect the hippie Trail and we
started in what is called the pudding
shop where if you ever saw a movie
called Midnight Express about a drug
dealer American drug dealer spent 10
years in prison that's where well that's
that's exactly where I started when I
first went on my trip with with with
Lacey and and and and the woman and the
other and the others Europeans who were
with us
um and we drove Acro and we began to
drive across Asia and we got in it
we were crossing Eastern Eastern Iran
one night a horse I don't know where it
was a white horse too uh jumped came
across the field jumped in the air
somehow we had panicked him and he fell
on in the front of the Volkswagen came
down kept running away but the
Volkswagen was now destroyed and it
could still dry but there was no window
at all it was all broken uh fortunately
as you know or may recall engines in the
back of a Volkswagen so we're okay and
we crawled along and we got to Michaud
and it took the rest of my money
uh that I had to repair the car here to
foreigners two Europeans were out there
in the middle of the Eastern Eastern
Iran let's charge these people a lot of
money and they did uh and so we made our
we got to the Afghan border
and I looked across the border and I
said
this is my Lawrence of Arabia land I had
seen the movie of Lawrence Arabia and
that that Romance of that to me the
romance of that of that type of life and
the romance of Afghanistan all came up
to me I could ride a camel Caravan and
disappear into into the midst uh there
was no border there was nothing there at
all no fence nothing and then we finally
we drove in
got into the country uh
got a Visa there at the border drove to
Kandahar
Kandahar we drove to up to up to Kabul
and as we approached Kabul I found
myself saying myself saying this is
shankara law why did I say that where
did it come from I have no idea
we stayed there as long as we could we
read about no more than a month we ran
out of money
um
I sold the car in the kyber pass for the
romance of it all but my brother on a on
a bus you could there were these hippie
buses that would with the money I had
uh made in selling the car and he made
his way back ultimately home a an
American school teacher who I met there
gave me enough money and I it was cheap
the cheapest way back was to fly from
Kabul to to Moscow back to Paris and
where I still had left my things I had a
12 full-length
wolf coat that I bought in the Bazaar in
in Kabul and
um
never forgot Afghanistan I went to work
I got my first job very serious young
man now as an aide to the senator from
Junior senator from Washington State
Senator Henry Jackson
and
74-77 and then I uh
I I left because I didn't like politics
I didn't I was I felt that it would
corrupt me I still this part of my
religious upbringing felt it I helped my
brother get a summer job and I felt I
was cheating in some way I was using my
position to to help him get a job I
didn't feel that that was right and so
we
I I got I I wrote I because of my
athletic background and the rise of
jogging at that at that time a friend of
I
friend of mine and I actually started
with his girlfriend came up with the
idea of writing a book on running and
Athletics and Recreation in Europe for
tourists and so we wrote a book
uh called a runner's guide to Europe and
didn't make any money but it uh
it was my entry into I used Athletics
Sports this is my entry into the world
of Journalism I was at a par I was still
living in Washington DC at the time I
went to a party and a man said there's a
program there was a newspaper strike in
in New York there's a program
called special edition they're looking
for people uh
why don't you do that and I oh so this
is what I'm going to do next this has
come to me it was sort of God was coming
to me providing this opportunity for me
and I went up there and I became a
commentator a sports
political commentator using my
background in Washington as well as my
athletic as well as my athletic
background
and then
in 1979
I was watching television
I saw the Soviet tanks
um intercable
and I was I was at home and with my
parents in Vancouver and I said I have
to return
I've got to go
just there was no question about it and
at that time nobody had gone from from
uh from the U.S a Dutch freelance
journalist had written articles that the
Washington Post reported and put on the
front page and that that instilled the
desire even more for me to go
and I went to the I went to The
Washington Post they said one woman said
how do I know because I worked for the
center you don't work for the CIA and I
said where did that come from and I
called I made 12 phone calls to the New
York Times
final phone call I said tired of me
calling come on up and I went and I sat
in this room with a foreign editor and
the deputy foreign editor and we talked
and then the second day we talked some
more and he said I made a lot of
charlatans in this business how do I
know that we can trust you
and they knew about my athletic
background because my name had been in
the paper there
and I said all I know about
and I quoted Camus who said oh who
played soccer as a boy in Algiers uh
and I said all I know about quoting him
all I know about uh ethics I know from
Sports
um you can't cheat and
that's what made them decide we're going
to go with this fellow and so what the
foreign editor the deputy foreign editor
did was that night
he took me into a room at New York Times
and he gave me an envelope and in that
envelope was 500 to check for 500 and a
small letter that said that I would be
doing research in New York New York
Times letterhead I'm going to do
research uh in South Asia
and
he said you can take this five hundred
dollars have the best night of your life
in New York you can apply to a plane
ticket to Afghanistan and you uh and you
can go to Pakistan and you can look
across the border and decide not to go
you can do whatever you want the money
is yours and that's all I needed they
trusted me
I I got I took my old army coat which
was not a smart thing to do I learned
later my fatigue jacket I got a pair of
uh and I a few other bits of clothes
that I thought would be necessary none
of which were and never didn't use
anything that was American and I flew to
flew to Karachi flew to Paris and then
from there to Karachi and then up to
Islamabad
where I met the New York Times
correspondent who took me to dinner or
it was lunch actually at a British Hill
station in in the uh north of north of
Islamabad after which we came outside
and he looked West towards Afghanistan
all we could see was was mountains and
trees and he said there lies deep as
dark as Afghanistan don't worry about
the story it will come to you and I felt
myself
sigh a bit I didn't realize that I was
scared that I was nervous
then I made my way to
up to Peshawar which is the old um to a
hotel or motel hotel called there was
once one one story only uh called Dean's
an old British hotel which I had been
told was that was the place I needed to
stay
and I found a driver
named munchie and me and he took me to
what was then the seven major political
religious parties the Pakistan allowed
in Pakistan's control of Afghanistan
Pakistan allowed to exist
and what I'm getting at here and I don't
want to make this too political is that
uh Pakistan very close Ally the United
States since 1954 in the Cold War
had its own agenda which it still has
today to try and because it cannot move
East against uh against against or
cannot move west against um
against or excuse me East against
um
um India
wants to recreate the Mughal Empire and
therefore and control Soviet what was
then Soviet Central Asia using the
mujahideen
which means holy Warriors are allies at
the same time the United States in order
to pay back and this has all been
documented pay back the Soviet Union for
providing arms to the North Vietnamese
we wanted to draw them into Afghanistan
to create for them their own Vietnam
uh I knew none of this when I first went
there all I knew was that I wanted to go
on this what will today call an
adventure I didn't consider that
Adventure uh I didn't use that word it
was just that I had to do this
and so I went from one group to another
uh with munchie and one said come come
with us we'll take you up it was North I
said well how long does it take to get
to get to your base you said a month and
I said no that's too long and I finally
went to I was about the sixth uh
mujahideen party I met with I went into
this
it's all Adobe or uh
houses and Adobe walls and went inside
this man bearded man bandolier pistol
sitting on the floor
drinking a glass of green tea
and
I said to myself
this is the man
my instinct said this is the man I want
to go with and what he was his name is
became very close to Osama Bin Laden
many years later and he Bin Laden when
he after 9 11 before he went up to
what's called torabora in the mountains
he stayed with yunus I didn't know the
world that I was about to enter
and the man a man with him said to me in
English what would you like to do and I
said I want to live with the mujahideen
I just knew instinctively that this was
the right place and later I realized
that he reminded me of some of the in
the way of the world in which I grew up
in very religious
but there was also a rifle present it
was not unlike you know people that I
grew up around
my father was didn't have a beard or
anything like that and this
uh made me to put a mildly very
comfortable I felt almost everything's
going to be fine they took me the next
day they took me a man came and knocked
on the door he took me to the bazaar had
me fitted out in Afghan clothes
a turban sandals
went back to the hotel the next day a
man came knocked on the door
got put me in a car
four men in the car we drove through
traffic stops in the middle of traffic
in the shower those two men get out two
men from nowhere I saw got in the car it
was the beginning
of my life with a very dark intriguing
no way that an outsider can understand
world of then the mujahideen today the
Taliban
we from there we crossed
into what are called the tribal areas of
Afghanistan the size of Connecticut
the headquarters many years later of Al
Qaeda
and the Taliban then the headquarters of
the mujahideen we made our way
into a place called Miriam Shah that
afternoon we stopped
and
they they they said you're on your own
in effect took me into a into a to a
compound a an adobe compound and then
they put me on the on the floor in a
small
in a small shed and in this shed were
stacks of pine boxes with black
letterings talking the type of
ammunition and the type of weapon that
was inside this is when the U.S the CIA
had already begun to supply them with
arms our allies our proxy army in
Afghanistan
three days later
uh
and I lived on
gritty rice and and and tea in that in
that very fly and mosquito infested
Place
shed two three days later A boy came
took me drove a Toyota pickup about half
a mile up into the mountain got out
uh I ate gritty rice with the family and
then we began to hike up into the
mountains and Men told me to take off my
shoes uh now the testing begins take off
my shoes I was making too much noise and
we and by the time we reached a tent
with a group of mojad Deen in it and my
feet were bloody uh
and I slept for a few hours and then we
made the next by Dawn the next morning
we made our way up by a series of guides
into
Afghanistan and I remember climbing high
and saying this is just like National
Geographic is how naive I was the next
day I came down into a down into a
valley passing we passed a Soviet base
with my uh Mi 24 helicopter gunships I
didn't know what they were at the time
beyond the fact that they were they were
giant helicopters and stayed with a man
named jalalandi nakani and his 17 other
men
I lived with them
for a month they we lived on gritty rice
and tea
they made sure that I ate before they
did they treated me like a king and at
that time there was no such thing as a
telephone no such thing as electricity
no roads no cars no way the outside
world if anything happened to you they
put you on a camel it took three days to
Pakistan
from there after living with them I made
my way South living with the with the
with the the mujahideen in Kandahar
a serious firefight
more than one one in particular made my
way by a camel with a rifle through out
from Afghanistan to to Pakistan came
back
to the New York Times and my first
article that ever wrote was on the front
page and I was totally consumed by the
world of Afghanistan and I continued in
that vein for the next five years
then
um
and went on through my life but then
I'm living in New York City
then I was no longer working for anybody
else I was trying to be I was trying to
become a writer I was working for a
private investigation firm on Wall
Street
on 9 11 I got up in the morning and I
was working on a on a book that I based
on actually a National Geographic
story that I had a project assignment
that I had and I got I noticed as we
approached Fulton Street and Subway
stopped that it became the trains that
went very very slowly and then we I got
to well the Wall Street Station we
walked up onto the street and was quiet
it was empty I said Somebody's either
there's either an accident or someone's
going to jump and I walked to the corner
and I saw the Flames across Rippling
across the World Trade Center I went up
to a cop and I said you know this
policeman I said uh what happened and he
told me we've got everything under
control and I walked over to over to the
World Trade Center and I looked straight
up and I said there was a woman with
black hair dark black hair coming down
and I said that and she's looking at it
when I said those windows don't open
they don't have anything under control
and then just in front of me the
wielding the building came crumbling
down like a deck of cards everybody
screamed
I ran like everybody else
eventually
eventually that night I that afternoon
we came home and that after that evening
I went out to go across the street to a
store on a woman who in my building
works with CBS said Afghanistan not
Hello not how are you just Afghanistan
and for the first time I thought oh
Afghanistan my small country
it All Began there I didn't think of
anything except the tragedy by then of
course I knew about Bin Laden I knew
about the rise of the Taliban
so the next days a uh CBS hired me three
days later and WABC television hired me
and I was but
three months later
they needed somebody for Afghanistan
I went
and unlike every other journalist there
I was not that interested I was
interested in the war but I was more
interested in finding the men I knew
from the 1980s all those the majidine
and
and I and I
I felt that I hadn't
my relationship with them was so deep
and I trusted them so much and they were
so good to me that it was something deep
inside of me that I couldn't leave it
and what became
and then so then
um I had a
um I had my own work to do and then I
had a
things I had to write
and then as I was finishing one I got a
call or an email that type that any
writer wants from the editor of times
the New York Times books
and he asked me to come back to New York
which I did we had breakfast in a in a
diner and he said
it's clear the CIA does not know
where Osama Bin Laden is hiding
we all know that the tribal areas of
Afghanistan of Pakistan size of
Connecticut
headquarters of the mujadin during the
1980s is where
Al Qaeda has its headquarters with the
Taliban have their headquarters no one
knows that place it's like a blank space
on the map can you go there
that's what I wanted
I could hardly wait
and so I began I I wanted to find the
econis if I could find the econis with
whom I'd lived in the 1980s I knew I
could find Bin Laden and the reason I
knew I could find Bin Laden is and I
would never have said anything like this
to anybody back in that in that time and
even now it sounds it sounds a bit
pretentious but
one time after I was there for about two
weeks at a Egyptian Army Major came
and lived with us he hated me because I
was American but I noticed how much
power he seemed to have over over
jalaladine accounting the leader of our
small band a small band of mujahideen
there and he allowed him even to use it
is demand that the Egyptians demand a
sam7 anti-aircraft missile
we only had three precious missiles then
and we tried to shoot down a Soviet
helicopter missed
and also now the Russians know where we
are
and
but there was something about the tie
between the Arabs and the and Angela
Dean that I knew then instinctively but
couldn't had no way of knowing there was
anything more than that that this is
somehow this war and Joel Dean and the
muja Deen are part of something larger
than Afghanistan I didn't know that that
man was the beginning of Al Qaeda
and only many many years did I realize
that and this is one reason why I knew
or sensed and felt and I still do and
actually events have borne me out that
that this is truly I was not wrong that
um
if I could get to July Dean to the
economies I could find out about Bin
Laden
um feeling because of the tide that I
had with them
and so ultimately this I lived I went
also
during this time I had a desire to and I
still do and I'm working on this right
now
um is to
oh boy I don't know how much I hope
you're gonna edit this
um
I was watching I was
it was 2006. I was watching I was
sitting in the CBS Newsroom
and I
was reading the New York Times and there
was an interview with Pat Tillman's
father
the NFL football star who was who had
joined the US Army and became a a a an
icon for so many people in America and I
said there's something about this death
that doesn't add up I've been in the
Army I have an athletic background I'm
from the West I grew up in a relatively
small town like not like San Jose but it
was
from the lesson I've I'd seen him on
television I felt a certain kinship to
him because he had said he didn't feel
that he had lived up to or he wasn't
equal to his ancestors who had fought in
Wars neither did I who did not have to
fight in Vietnam feel that I was equal
to my ancestors particularly my father
who had done so much in the Marine Corps
in the Pacific in World War II
and
so I went to everybody at CBS and he
said it's a great idea Jerry but no it's
too expensive we don't have the money
and it's too dangerous
but on my own I used my own money I went
went back to Afghanistan
and I with through my contacts went to
the canyon twice or been where Tillman
was killed and I had held on to that and
to find out from that side what really
happened to him and why and it was that
trip my first time wearing Afghan
clothes growing a beard going back up
into the mountains of Afghanistan that I
said I want to do this again I want to
live up here I want to in some ways as I
suppose return to the to the
the adrenaline I felt the closest I felt
my belief in in my respect for these men
who had nothing but treated me so well
and to me there was really no
distinction between the Africa between
the mujahideen and the Taliban I found
out later
about where I was wrong but at that time
I didn't so I returned to the mountains
uh
Li dressed as an afghan
living for seven months off and on
up in the mountains meeting with the
Taliban taking risks going ever
ever deeper into that world
and I remember clearly one time
near not far from Tora Bora going up
there with a drone overhead
and I said how am I going to survive
this but the Taliban knew that the Drone
was that drone was over there we could
hear it suddenly they have a lot at that
time that one had a lot an engine that
sounded like a lawnmower
but to this day I think the reason they
didn't do anything is because they saw
my pen and they saw the notebook that I
had I was dressed like an Afghan my
beard was long I was living the world in
the world that I had come to enjoy and
feel so much a part of where I felt so
alive in the 1980s
um finally
the my my guides
said that we're
we finally have arranged it we can find
and I've skipped over a hundred things
on how we arranged all this but we
decided they're going to take me deeper
into the tribal areas where I would find
the economies and
we arranged this trip
Taliban I remember the day before
the evening before I got a call from my
fixer
saying the Taliban guide is crossing the
border from Pakistan
we're on he didn't say we're on but in
effect we are going I remember clearly I
was I had gone to a mosque and attended
a
prayer service
to see most importantly is can I blend
in well people not I'm not Muslim no not
at all and I was in some ways it's I
suppose sacrilegious uh but I didn't
feel that and I don't truly believe that
I was being
I had to find a way to
blend in entirely and could I pass
praying that I know how to do this then
I took one final walk through the bazaar
um can I pass can I buy I knew how to my
language was was not good but I know
enough or knew enough at the time how to
buy it two oranges and pay for that and
walk on and use that in X number of
sentences once I started with a
paragraph I can't do anything
and then I felt
it was time to go and something deep in
this the first time I'd ever felt in my
life this pit in my stomach telling me
what you're about to do is very
dangerous
I made my way back to the to the guest
house an Afghan guest house where we
were staying
the Talib
Taliban by the way is the plural Talib
means Seeker it means student in Persian
in in Pashto
a Talib is a is a religious student he
is also someone a Seeker seeking God
seeking spiritual enlightenment and
Taliban of course is therefore the
plural
and so this Taliban come across he was
waiting and he was in our in our room
and that night
I got a phone call
from a member of an Afghan Member of
Parliament who was part who I had used
as an intermediary to arrange part of
this trip
um
and he said and he told me that there
was a Pakistani army officer who had
been kidnapped by the Taliban there are
too many soldiers in the area it was too
dangerous for me to go what he was
saying was that
um would I have
what has happened is this it's become
far more dangerous than what I thought
it would be when I arranged for you to
go on this trip in the first place
that's that's was in essence what he was
saying but he couldn't say it on the
phone because the phone would be tapped
and so then
for the first time
I remember saying trust your instincts
always trust your instincts Jerry and
for the first time I ignored them
I said I have to do this I have to go
and the next morning
we had breakfast in this in this
in this guest house
and my fixers the man who I'd arranged
to be my intermediary
uh we had the Taliban guide
and my fix's father came and I gave him
all my everything I had my passport
because I could not in any way wear
western clothes I now had to be deep
into Afghanistan I had to pass like I
felt I was able to pass in the 1980s
yeah
we CR we drove we got close to the
Border we drove
from the hotel close to the Border
went on a dirt road Dirt Road ended and
my fixer said to me
give give gas money to our driver
I went close to the driver
you give him the money and I saw his
eyes were watery
and he came close to me and he did
something no Afghan actually no man has
ever done to me
he kissed me on the cheek
and he said go with God
he said something else that I did not
understand but I knew later what he was
saying was is that
I know you're going to be kidnapped I
know you may not may not return you
probably won't
but I can't tell you and I've enjoyed it
and I like you but go with God his
watery eyes
some would say he was and I thought this
for a time was it was a Judas kiss that
he was betraying me I don't believe that
today I believed it for a long time I
don't believe it anymore
and we
we left
and we began to hike up into the
mountains that evening it was going
single file
20 meter 20 yards apart my
uh
lead bodyguard with a rifle clashnikov
in the lead 20 yards behind him another
man with a classic
then me and then behind me my fixer who
was overweight and always 20 30 40 yards
behind
and I looked up as we're going into this
Valley and I saw a tinge of black
move
behind a rock and I knew instinctively
that's not a goat that's not a black
sheep
and then by the time then I could I
could feel the pit in my stomach I felt
fear all over me and then that black
tinge all of a sudden the man Rose of
the black turban Mohammed wore a black
turban in Taliban wear black turbans
raised his rifle High
10 12 men came spread out running down
this path running down there down the
ridge can that kind of can I get down
get down and I said I'm dead
I'm dead I'm dead
and I had cottonmouth
and
a man in the center with a with a
walkie-talkie the only one who had that
equipment you know technology if you
will
came up to me
stared at me
where were you where did you come from
and where are you going
and I tried to answer this in Pashto
there's no I'm now it's if he founds out
America I'm done I'm done and
um I mispronounced bashawar it's called
pekkoar in that dialect in the mountain
there and he said you're not Afghan and
they took me up up into the they grabbed
me and what bothered me also is that
when the rifles came down or that my
bodyguards never fired their weapons
and I knew something was wrong something
was strange something was going on that
I didn't comprehend all I knew was that
I was now being led up in the mountain
came on top of the ridge
they put me down faced me West
blindfolded me hands behind me tied my
hands
and I thought of and when you get blind
when you're blindfolded you lose all
sense of power all sense of of
Independence uh or the ability to do
anything you are totally at the totally
of the mercy of those who have
blindfolded you and I remember looking
West and the weather was warm and gently
there was this Breeze and I said it's
like California remember that and I
looked I looked and I West and I thought
of my father my mother had died and my
brother my sister
and they put a rifle put the rifle
across the coffee against my temple I
could hear that and they talked and they
took it away and then cocked it and I
just was like a sheep waiting to be
slaughtered in a in a
slaughterhouse
I was so it was shock just pure shock
and I just waited my back straight I
have to look straight ahead I can't bend
down I have to look good from my family
and or look at least with an essence of
of
self-pride about it
and of course they didn't do anything
they grabbed me took me down into a down
the mountain
put me into a car
we drove I don't know where or how for
how long maybe two hours gravel road
dirt road gravel road dirt roads maybe
we drove in circles I don't know it
pulled me out on the ground went all
over I mean tried to find and took some
money what little money I had
asked if I was Muslim
uh and I had to
I had two for the first time well I
tried to think that I don't lie but
I I responded in in Arabic a little
Arabic that I know and
whether that made any difference or not
I don't know it back in the car and now
I'm alone in the back of this car before
my body got one of my bodyguards and one
of my pictures was there inside even
though I was blindfolded
I I knew they were there because one
tried to hold my hand or wrote something
on my hand
and
then it we began to climb up a dirt and
gravel road I remember the car couldn't
make it uh it finally got going and I
know they're going to take me up to a
Mountaintop and they're going to kill me
they're going to behead me and what
happens is when you become
when you become kidnapped and you're
blindfolded in Afghanistan will no
longer I'm somewhere in Pakistan is that
everything all of a sudden has changed
it's primal
everything is Primal it's about how am I
going to not I know I'm going to die I
know they're going to kill me I know
they're going to behead me and there's
you just accept it there's nothing I can
do I just have to do this with a certain
amount of dignity how can I withstand
and this is what I've learned more as
much as anything if not more is is how
long will the pain be how long will it
last before I'm dead that's what you
worry about and
we kept climbing and climbing and then
we came to a place and
I heard the dogs bark
and they took me out of the of the car
put my hand against the wall and could
feel the Adobe the dirt and baked mud
wall and dog sparking and into a room
and
um they took off my off my
my blindfold and I was happy for about
30 seconds because I saw my two
bodyguards and my fixer there I wasn't
alone
and I looked at the wall and I looked
for blood on the wall and there was a
cut a rope cut that's four of them in
the room
stake in the ground with chains in it
and I said I am deep somewhere deep in
the mountains of Pakistan in a Taliban
prison and no one can find me
and the man came up to me and he asked
who was your father
and what is your father's name that is
deep deep Afghanistan that means that
the only thing that what matters most
the most important question in
Afghanistan is who is your grandfather
it is a tribal culture it is a world
where you are judged by your family in
the family being part of the tribe a
central government a sense of democracy
as we know it here in the west that's
all totally irrelevant it's irrelevant
this is very ancient tribal Mountain
Afghanistan
but I was deep into Pakistan now
somewhere deep into Pakistan the
pashtunes the largest ethnic group in
Afghanistan
there are more pashtoons in Pakistan
across the border than in Afghanistan
the Border was drawn by the British when
they ruled there and and made it two
countries in 1947 when the British
finally left
and I realized that I could not keep
this charade going anymore and I had
said I was my real name is this and I
waited for again for them to kill me the
um where it became
hard
truly hard
uh the first time was about three days
three days later it was midnight it was
late at night it's late I have no idea
what the exact time was we were allowed
out about five minutes if that three to
five minutes at night makeshift toilet
and I
I
that each man went outside they took my
bodyguards out and they took the fixer
out and then they came back
and then they came to me
and they faced me toward every and then
by now they're about 20 men in this room
and the Taliban leader took my camera
they are they taking everything I had I
had a small
small film camera with me
they took everything when they got me
and he said how do I turn this on he
thrusted at me
and I knew what was coming and I said oh
you're about
to film me and you want me to help you
fill my own execution
now they had a group of men behind me
with their rifles
and
the hardest thing to do
when you think of those hostages the
American hostages they were murdered by
ISIS it's so much courage it took me
forever it seemed for me to lift my back
up I I had my back I had facing the
facing the floor
spent over
because I did not I just didn't want to
I didn't want to I don't even say it I
didn't want to sit up straight
with my back straight my mother when I
was a boy always told me step straight I
did I couldn't do that because by
sitting up straight now my my neck is
exposed
and
and be over there one time there's a
there was small they had these a small
little chair a guy sat on maybe six
inches eight inches off the ground
chewing on a piece of wheat and with a
Kalashnikov and his on his in his lap
and I said to myself
ask myself how do you want to die you
want to die by a clash in the cuff
spraying bullets across your chest
or do you want to be beheaded
whatever comes first that's what I want
it's the alleviation of pain
um
years later
I met in New York with a fellow named
Terry White
who was sent by the Archbishop of
Canterbury to
Lebanon to Beirut to try and negotiate
the release
of hostages there
he was in prison he kept him in
captivity for four years some of that
was
in solitary confinement we met and had
coffee in New York and what he wanted to
talk about more than anything else
mock executions
that was what that bothered him that
hurt him that
stuck with him
all those years that that's what he
wanted to talk about and
it took me a very long time before
because they did it twice the Taliban
went through this charade
and then they stopped and went back
outside they came in a second time
and this time I was wearing this small
Afghan hat it's like looks like a
pancake hat you see it on television
it took it off
exposed my head
they took they took the clash in the
cough which is come which is cut at an
angle it's not like a rifle in America
with it or or a pistol it's kind of at
an angle and they pushed it not too hard
but they pushed it enough into my temple
The Man Behind
took out the knife that long
the like that they use it to slaughter
Buffalo Water Buffalo or sheep
and
um
I lifted my arm up
and
that and then
he stopped they didn't do anything else
came down
but I realized
at that moment that that that night was
the worst night of my life
it's also the best night one of the best
nights maybe the best night of my life
and what I'm saying is
is that
I had the courage
to look my killer in the eye
because the man looked at me
and he kept staring at me and I knew I
was willing to fight my father would not
be ashamed my family would not be
ashamed
finally at this time I kept my back
straight and I said it's just you and me
I looked at the Taliban Commander go
ahead
let's go
what I was saying was if you're going to
kill me I'm going to fight
what I got from that was
[Applause]
oh my God
they had the courage to face my killer
I wasn't a coward
I'd gone to Afghanistan I think because
I hadn't been in the military
and fought in the War
measure up
to my father
to be a man
the Taliban gave me that
they frightened me to death
but I had the courage ultimately I found
face my killer my back was straight
I was able to say goodbye to my mother
my mother was already gone to my father
to my brother and my sister
I remember
they put their rifles away they left
I stumbled over to my God
put my head down on us
I cried for about
two seconds
and I couldn't cry in front of them I
couldn't be a coward
then
I don't know when two weeks maybe later
um
they came in one night and they said or
when late one day it was nice toward
dusk
and they said well there were two things
happened one
a man said to me we can do anything we
want to you here and no one can find you
and then they said we want we're going
to ask for 1.5 million dollars and three
men from Guantanamo
and then a man said to me and he called
me a monkey
behind my back I didn't understand that
word of course
and I said to myself I'm gonna I may
have survived that but I'm in a very
very dangerous one
situation here were your parents were
your was your family
aware no one knew
no one knew well at that time
what I had no idea of
was that they had begun when they when
they said that we're asking 1.5 million
and three men from Guantanamo what they
were asked what they had begun to do
was negotiate and that friends of mine
people men I knew who worked with CBS
afghans
knew everybody a lot of people and by
now people the journalist community in
Kabul uh at within days Jerry's
disappeared he's gone and things had
started to move I knew nothing of this
all that was going on on the outside
didn't have a clue I knew everything
that was going on I think I knew
everything was happening in that cell
but I had no idea what was happening on
the outside so they had begun to
negotiate and what I thought I had to do
was find 1.5 million dollars to pay the
ransom
to get out of there to survive and I was
and so what I had done under tremendous
under pressure was give my phone give
the phone number of my family to them
because I knew I was going to have to
take money from my brother and my sister
from my father take money away from my
brother and sister's children's college
education to pay for my to pay for my
release so all of this not all of a
sudden but now I'm causing trouble to my
own family
which
made me feel anything but strong
that and they wanted to even bring in my
fixer's father this was all a charade
this part as as the collateral in a bank
you can put up something else when this
case you put up a human being
and so while this negotiation was going
on they were trying to use me to do to
get money what I could but the problem
is that they use that phone number and
they called my family
frightening
frightening them there
that my brother's wife gets a phone call
or my sister gets a phone call from the
Taliban at the same time the state
department
uh
and the FBI had begun to contact my
family
and they haven't they have a system they
put in play the FBI not the CIA is in
charge of American kidnappings around
the world uh this goes back to in the
1930s or I forget exactly when it was
when the
um
uh the Char the
it was a kidnapping went from they
transferred a kidnapping case from uh
the boy was kidnapped
um the Lindbergh boy Lindbergh child was
kidnapped in New York or in New Jersey
and whoever kidnapped him
took him across the board across the
state lines into New York there by
giving Hoover an opportunity to use the
FBI expand the FBI's control from just
it became a federal case and they
expanded that to include now the whole
the whole world it's not the CIA
although they played a role in my case
and they play a role I'm sure in others
but it's the FBI in charge and so those
two entities were in contact with my
family and CBS was
operating in its in the foreign editor
was doing everything she could so all of
this was going on that I knew nothing
but what became difficult where
everything changed again was
that one day the the my main Jailer came
in and he said
that one of their Commander's Sons I
think it was a son not a daughter I
needed a new kidney and they wanted to
take mine or maybe they would take the
main vein and I don't know what it's
called them in vain that goes from
you're going down to your to your foot
and I said no
yeah I'm not going to allow a man to
come in here with a syringe tie me down
uh
knock me out do something and kept me
take my kidney and so no that's not
going to happen because every time
the door opened when they brought food
in
for us I would look outside
which way is west which way are the men
praying uh which way is which way is
Mecca which way would I go if I have to
run towards Pakistan or run towards
Afghanistan how do I get out of here
that's what you're trying to do your
whole life is spent trying to maintain
this tie to your Jailer and the men
around you at the same time
stay alive and figure out how do I
escape I got to get out of here that's
that's what is a it's a constant and so
I said I'm leaving I if I'm not I'm not
this is not good no this is not going to
happen and I Pace the room like a tiger
in a cage that you see in a zoo back and
forth back and forth Gotta Go Gotta Go
that night
a man one of my bodyguards
who said it was on the other other side
of the room stayed about 10 minutes
outside maybe in 15 minutes outside when
it was time to go to the bathroom toilet
which was simply a place on the ground
that they had for us and then the next
time then the Jailer came in and he came
up to me about six inches from my face
if you try to do anything like Escape I
will come at you like a dog
at that moment I knew
that I had been betrayed that I nobody I
could not trust anybody in that room and
it went from being a primal experience
to reptilian
and for the first time I wanted to kill
somebody I wanted to harm somebody badly
I lay in that cot at night and I'd look
across at My Bodyguard and all I saw was
blood all over him I have never had that
feeling in my life so you become a very
completely different person totally come
cut off from what we'll call
Society if you will
um it's all Beyond Primal it's reptilian
and
at the same time you have to at the same
time you have to you find yourself this
is a very delicate thing especially in
our in our in Western culture is
and people have said this to me a lot
it's called Stockholm syndrome that our
Jailer would go away sometimes go away
for two days three days once he came in
and grabbed a ammunition that we in the
corner there in a box of ammunition and
he was he walked out with that
um
that I wanted when he came back I felt
better because he was good to me he
brought food to me he was I had become
somehow trusted I trusted him in a way
there's no way I should trust him but I
did trust him so it's it's what happens
to the human psychic it happens to
people who are totally dependent upon
somebody for food and for security and
the weight the only way I could live and
it was so important is to
acknowledge that deal with that without
betraying yourself without giving
anything away without showing weakness
without betraying anybody else and it
was it's it's a double-edged sword but
it's something that I was able to
negotiate
um ultimately
um one day
it was that night the night before the
Jailer was very relaxed
and he left the door open even for a
while and
he was there but the door was open
um
and the next the next day he came in and
he with a woman's chadri the women where
you see photos of Afghan women in the
streets he brought that in and threw it
on the threw it on the on caught put it
on
so I put it on
and I knew we were going and they took
me downstairs I didn't know outside and
downstairs I didn't know I was on the
top of of a house there were people
living in the in the room below us
and
out to a car I could feel a lot of
people around me so they disguised you
as a woman I was a woman I was disguised
as a woman which in Afghanistan are
fully covered fully covered I was
completely covered uh so they they have
a chance of getting you out of there
without
very good point because no one no one
has realized what you just said no one
is really honed in on that uh and all
the times I've had to tell the story in
various ways
it's exactly right and they had to find
a way to get me out of that crowd out of
that Village wherever we were
I have no idea where we were
um
only that and this is important later on
only that I knew that there was a drone
overhead so somehow the United States
knew was it knew where we were in what
area we were somehow they had figured
this out
as only only about a month ago maybe six
weeks now that I learned how they did
learned what how that transpired in a
bit
um
and so
the
as we began to drive
I heard this two things here one one day
this is political but this is important
uh one small thing is that not small but
important is that one day my Jailer said
the political agent he mentioned the
words political agent I'll come back to
that in a minute uh a political agent
well a bit a political agent is
something created by the British that
controls each tribal area I was in the
tribal areas when you think of a tribal
area think of like the Navajo
reservation or the any other uh Indian
Reservation or in America only far
larger this is the way that the British
tried to control that region at the time
when they were there
um
today the tribal the the political agent
uh reports directly
to the prime minister of Pakistan
I remember when I was we're going the
car started to move I'm dressed as a
woman
uh they're people all around I can hear
people all around us I'm blindfolded of
course I'm blindfolded and I have the
chaudrey over me it's hot
and I hear a horn very small a horn beep
like there's somebody else behind us
there's another car here somewhere or
maybe that was our car
um
and I tried to I tried to roll the
window down and stick my head out and he
thought I was trying to escape and he
pulled this and he he cocked his rifle
and
uh I didn't realize then how close I was
he made it very clear that he had
chambered a bullet in the whether he was
trying to show off or not
Taliban guys don't show off they don't
have to uh
that he had said he'd chambered
chambered a bullet that they were under
as much pressure
as not as much as I was but they were
what they were doing was maybe back by
somebody else and I do believe that it
got out of control
and that they were they were in control
they were in control of me
but what they were doing was if anybody
found out then they would be in trouble
um otherwise why worry so much about
my being discovered by some villager so
um
I we finally we finally um
made the same I don't know where we went
I have no idea uh but then we we got to
uh this field and they and they took my
I they took off my Chaudhary and I
looked at the Sun and for the first time
in in since I was kidnapped I saw the
sun how many weeks has it been six and a
half weeks and
um
then
we began to hike up into a hill and we
going and they stopped and I saw a man
looking at a at a
going through something on the ground
and I said oh
that's a suicide that's that's a suicide
bombers gear they're going to put that
on me they're gonna they're gonna send
me out as a suicide bomber they said
that one thing that I had to do and I
didn't discuss this I had to listen for
hours and hours and hours to Taliban
suicide tapes
and they talked about training me to be
a suicide bomber to go against the
Pentagon
and they wanted to in addition of course
to survive if I wanted to get out of
there I had to convert to Islam so I was
playing a very delicate game of praying
but not praying and going through the
motions but but I certainly couldn't
mock them and
there was
on one hand and this goes back to my
childhood there was a certain comfort
in that in that as it was comfort with
what I was with the economist before his
very violent men it's a world of rifles
and
death and War at the same time it's a
world of religion and the hardship
involved was something that is instilled
in to me as a boy to be tough to be out
in the to be able to you know one match
the light of fire
um
and to learn how to ride a horse as a
boy uh
was something my father instilled with
me that in certain ways manifested
itself or became
um without my knowing it made me
comfortable with the mujahideen and
eventually with the Taliban the
difference between the muja Deen and
Taliban is once a Soviet helicopter came
over us when I was with the mujahideen
and we were in the part of our compound
that was filled with ammunition there
were all these pine boxes with them in
English of the weapons and the type of
ammunition by then that the CIA was
supplying to the econis and the
helicopter was right on top of us just
hovering above us all he had to do was
drop one bomb and the whole
Valley would have blown up uh and the
man in front of me against the wall was
shivering in fear
the Taliban even with a drone overhead
walked in and out of my cell with no
fear that the sense of martyrdom the
sense of dying was so much greater and
easier for the Taliban in the mujahideen
I attribute that to The Exchange in
Afghanistan when I first went to
Afghanistan in 1973 there was a
discotheque in the street in in Kabul
there were 11 movie theaters or outdoor
cafes Afghanistan was not a not a
radical
environment at all there were six
thousand hippies in Kabul in the 19 in
the 1970s when I was there it look at
academic research they introduced if
he's introduced Afghans to the drug
trafficking World International drug
trafficking markets uh there were uh the
world of I could I remember once hearing
the real music and called a prayer the
Rolling Stone I could hear The Rolling
Stones mixed with a Jefferson Airplane
next to the evening called a prayer the
Taliban are the result of the
arabization of Afghanistan I want to get
political here what that means is that
the U.S and its l by Saudi Arabia with
Pakistan in order to fight the Soviet
Union be brought in
so many in the 911 Commission only dealt
with this somewhat brought in thousands
of Afghan of Arabs out of which came Al
Qaeda and from which we get
Isis today
and so it made it it's made Afghanistan
a much more conservative violent world
than it was when I went there as a boy
which made it so romantic which is why
there were so many hippies there why it
was so appealing you see these long
camel Caravans come through the streets
silent in the afternoon sun it was with
these women in bare feet and unveiled by
the way the Taliban never got any Nomad
any Nomad woman ever to take off for
Veil don't think for a minute that
Afghan women are simply used by men and
have no power whatsoever very very
strong people especially the nomads
which is who still exists
um which is part of the romance of
Afghanistan so the
the as when I saw that suicide I thought
there was a suicide bomber there who was
preparing to either blow himself up or
attach it to me and I envisioned myself
uh having that strap to me and they were
forcing me when we were going to come to
the place where I envisioned my sister
uh carrying a carrying a briefcase with
1.5 million dollars in it because I had
no idea what happened on you no idea
that that we're going to come to
exchange and then on one area the a boy
would be going through where my sister
was with other Americans and such
waiting for me
a little boy would blow himself up and
at the same time I envisioned Apache
helicopters coming in
of course none of that transpired we the
man was I don't to this day I don't know
what he was doing but I thought it was a
suicide bomb we we began to hike and we
hiked for hours and hours and hours and
and I remember
being about 30 yards behind the Taliban
leader and I said all I have to do is
run up to him I didn't have much energy
but I was so
this is how you think grab his rifle I
can shoot him uh of course that never
happened
we finally
and finally after that night we find
they finally stopped
they said I leaned over I could hardly
walk
we know where your family is we know uh
how to reach your family we have your
phone number
um
we're going to be watching you now go
and we kept walking and by then it was
late at night and I fell down a few
times in a in the dirt and
we kept walking and then after a while
uh I don't know if it's cigarette
lighters or what small what kind of
lights they have but all of a sudden
uh one of my guides
had a a light went on and we could see
these lights coming toward us and Men
came up and they hugged me just gently
and to this day I'm almost positive they
were not completely Taliban they had too
much Weaponry on them they were not just
one rifle they were because I could just
feel all this pistol and whatever else
they were carrying
meaning this was not simply a Taliban
operation
um
these things do not happen in a vacuum
that's all I can say about that
but
finally we we crossed we came to a river
we crossed a river on a boat
truck a pickup truck took me uh
picked me up from there we drove on for
20 minutes or so we came to another area
near Another River
and
we waited and then a man went down to
the river and flipped a light on the
other side another light came
and came on and it what was a Toyota
pickup I didn't know it at the time what
it was came down blinked his lights
stopped at the stopped at the water's
edge
and a
[Music]
Ferry you know hand and rope Ferry no
electricity no no no no gasoline no
nothing remotely modern just came Acro a
barge came across with a rope pulley
and they put me on the they put me on
the ferry
with some of the Taliban my bodyguards
we crossed the river and my bodyguards
took their hand one of them took their
hands and on my beard which is a sign of
is pleading with me don't betray me
don't turn me in we're saving you we
haven't heard harmed you don't tell the
Americans where we are that's what he
was saying by by pulling on my beard and
we uh got to the other side they could
not cross they could not that was
Afghanistan my fixer and I
got off
got in to the pickup
we went for maybe a half hour
stopped again I saw a man holding a
lantern like that like a like a they
doing a railroad
um here in the U.S and I thought oh no
the Taliban again and I
I how am I gonna I can't look like an
American how do I handle this
and then we waited there in a SUV an SUV
came out
and
it was the tribal leader from that area
everything is tribal and the tribal
Chief was the one who was in charge it
was a tribal Chief who my friends had
all the people who were looking for me
had
worked with
and it was he who drove me and then so
he came out and behind him was another
SUV with rifles out the window on both
sides probably half a dozen men at least
in there all armed my bodyguards now and
they drove me for maybe an hour and we
came to jalalabad in Afghanistan came
about 50 yards from the U.S base
the tribal Chief got out of the car and
walked away and they drove me into the
base and the driver inexplicably knew
exactly what Afghan knew exactly where
to go to clean around and into this
place where they had a Cyclone Fence set
up with a with a house or a
sheet metal type of corrugated metal
house building
took me in there closed the thing off
and two three uh Americans guys grab me
took me out and carried me or picked me
up and
brought me into a room
and there I was there were
a guy with long hair pistol on his side
and so where do you want to go you want
to go to Kabul or you want to go to
Bagram which is the air base I had no
idea one meant the Army one went the FBI
they they checked me for my health and
gave me some food I didn't I wasn't the
least bit hungry and then I had no idea
so I just said Kabul because that would
be
closer and we the next day
uh and then the FBI they took me to the
FBI and they took over from there they
had a plane waiting a special forces guy
was with us very good man even he and
his wife sent me a send me a note a few
months later
um
and I took me to this
and then drove into the embassy
where uh found a place for me to sleep
but I was not the least bit tired and
then I
the Ambassador and and other officials
were there and then they had me uh talk
to the CIA
and
and then
um put me on a plane
and the FBI brought me back to America
to New York
and that was in JFK the as we
um
walking down the walking down the the
through the hallway empty never seen
empty never seen everything Customs
before just the police the FBI and me
into the Customs where they stamp your
passport and everybody turned and looked
at this man with long hair and long
beard skinny as a rail holding his pants
up who in the world is that and it was
me and the guy stopped smiling he said
here then we have to stamp your passport
took me off and then we walked off the
uh through customs into a room big table
all these FBI guys there and put his
hand on my shoulder and welcome home
Jerry welcome home you're safe you're
safe I said can they get me here and he
said no man across the table said but
check your phone when you go home the
talibanum called you we want to know
what we'd like to know what they said I
said they followed me back here
uh no cameras no television cameras at
all I'm
the foreign minister for foreign editor
at CBS came and she brought me back to
my apartment
and I not married and there was a that
night I saw the Taliban on the wall and
I woke up saw the Taliban the next day
and when I went for running Central Park
and
along the way
um I got a call
from some people who are responsible and
one was an MI6 agent British
intelligence
and an Afghan said to me or a CBS bureau
chief in London said Jerry the FBI
didn't do anything it was he gave me
this man's name saved your life
I would have gone to Perth or to
Johannesburg the farthest place on the
planet to find this man he came to
Washington he took me we had dinner and
we went to a house we were staying and
we talked and he said
we did everything possible
to
to prevent a second Daniel Pearl
I was the next person kidnapped in
Pakistan next journalist kidnapped in
Pakistan after Daniel Pearl Daniel Pearl
was slaughtered
when I was facing the camera
and the Taliban were trying to and the
Taliban put the rifles
to my temple I thought of Daniel Pearl
and
um
so what happened was that
eventually and then he said
you have no idea what the Ripple effects
will be
and he's been working this this MI6
British MI6 agent like CIA
[Music]
couldn't have
he was absolutely right you can divide a
kidnapping up into two parts everything
happens inside and everything that
happens afterwards uh and they're almost
equal
um
and a kidnapping never goes away
and
so
one day
um
I was giving a talk in New York for a
group of journalists
and the man who introduced me used that
phrase he said how can I introduce you I
can say the thing about Daniel Pearl
and then he
a fellow came up to me with his
girlfriend now his wife
and he had a British accent and he said
do you think he would have survived if
you were Jewish
but I've taken aback by that and then I
realized
later
um
that my
fixer asked if I ate pork
and my Jailer later asked me the same
thing
Daniel Pearl was massacred by Al Qaeda
and I was I was
I was released
and why was I released
I still haven't figured everything out
spent I've written a book on why I went
back in 2017 to figure out who really
kidnapped me and why
because when they ask about the
political agent and not one American has
ever asked me about about the political
agent but I made a trip to walk to
London to and I talked to the British
police and the only about
Scotland Yard people about kidnappings
and that they said we're not going to
tell you anything but they asked me what
did the political agent say
the only people who've ever asked me
about the political agent not one person
in America even seemed to know about the
political agent who support who goes
directly to the Pakistani government
so uh
a kidnapping is not in my case was not
as simple asking for money in exchange
it was far more political than that and
I still haven't resolved it everything
that happened
but I do spend a great deal of my life
now involved with Afghanistan with
dealing with kidnapping cases and
missing Americans
part of the missionary in me I suppose
and the one who feels unobligated that
my father wanted me to be and the
Mission I feel that desire I feel the
necessity the obligation because I
survived
to help others out there
because there are missing Americans
there are hostages in Afghanistan today
I'm positive of that even though you
don't read about it and um
it gives me a
one thing's purpose in life
how have you changed from all of this
how's it affected you
today
right here with you
I trust you
the question
I worry about
I talk about Pakistan
um
dangerous thing to do
about a month ago
I'll come back to that about a month ago
a woman I know in New York
a lawyer
went out with a middle 20 years ago
um
send me an email she said I was in
Washington at a cyber security
conference event meeting something
probably to do with her work I don't
have any idea
and she said there was a woman there
and she held up your book
and she said
this book I wrote about my kidnapping
called captive
I found Jerry I'm the one who who you we
planted that were the drones because I
figured it out so some nondescript not
saying on the script
so I'm very
ordinary looking woman married or not
lives in some suburb or not
was able to with her incredible skills
find where I was where I was being kept
they put a drone up there as a result
which changed the dynamic in the room
for I was no longer completely alone
at the mercy and man who said we can do
what he's sitting next to me I can do
whatever we want to you and no one will
find you
then all of a sudden a drone was up
there and my picture said can the camera
see inside it gave me a sense of hope
and it gave me a sense and gave me power
within within the Taliban that they I
felt that one reason they didn't kill me
I have no idea why ultimately but
because she did that
not about through because she was able
to to
do what she did with her linguistic
abilities or whatever she however she
was able to figure out
by tracing phone calls that they were
making with maybe with my people with
the CBS people or my family or whatever
I have no idea and then and then also
about
maybe two months ago three months ago
now
uh if you recall the U.S after the
Taliban had now in power
the U.S launched a drone attack and
killed Iman al-sawahari
the leader after Bin Laden dot was
killed the leader of the Taliban and
they found him in a house
they traced him by drones or however the
CIA did this uh
owned by
either one member of the economies or
one
or someone related to the economies this
group that I lived with in 1981
um
the economy
the mujahideen there are 18 of them
all from the same tribe
the leader with jalaladin and his
younger brother Ibraham was 19 at the
time
um
five years later half of them were dead
and today the economy Network as the U.S
calls it and its allies is
with the demise of Bin Laden and the
family
meaning as one of his sons
is that it is in my view
the most influential most powerful
jihadist group in the world
and Suraj Edina Khan Angel Ali and Sons
military commander of the Taliban I'm in
touch with him today
um they're in touch with me
the
they are without a doubt in the center
of the Taliban powerful force in the
world today
we killed uh
the CIA the Army whomever
launched that drone they killed I'm an
al-sawary also launched
a week later
a drone or a a
an attack on a man named Abdul Wali
Abdullah
was in charge of my kidnapping
yeah
I never met him
thank goodness
but he was The Mastermind I was told he
was behind it
and they killed him with a drone three
months ago or shortly after they killed
elsewhere
brought everything back brings it back
right now
kidnapping doesn't it
and as the MI6 agent said you have no
idea what the Ripple effects will be
I've never told that story publicly
before and that's why I cried I think
the emotion inside
do you feel in some way that you
ask for this
because of the way you live because
you're you're attraction to Adrenaline
filled
travel and
exploration and journalism and all that
kind of stuff
do you feel like you brought this on
yourself
what happened to me or being here today
no no what happened to you in
Afghanistan when you were kidnapped
no one's ever asked me that
I bring it on
my answer is the Wells up inside of me
is yes
I
my editor
second book I wrote about my going back
to try and find out a kid named me and
why
use the word suicidal
you said you were practically suicidal
if not suicidal in what I was doing
going with the Taliban time and time
again risking everything
um
I had to do it I was driven by by
what I don't know I didn't know I just
had to do it
um
I have been living on that on that edge
since
or I've been living like that since I
took that first trip
um out of college
which was
like a religious Journey looking for the
god that
I knew God to
not the God that I betrayed or had
betrayed me
I think that everything that inside of
us that's their childhood
does not go away
um
no it doesn't go away
I feel that
someone said to me the other night
you've devoted your life to Afghanistan
I didn't like to hear that
but there's there's truth in that
you can feel you can control life or you
can feel that you are LED I felt that I
in that prison
I did all I could instinctively
without any background to to stay alive
I don't
I don't feel one
bit of regret
I feel I did everything and I hate to
even talk this way I feel I did
everything right in that prison to stay
alive and to not
betray myself my family
or to
show weakness
yeah I do once I got out that's a
completely different story
the PTSD doctor that the FBI put on me
two years of
nothing of which well a few things were
good but it was a very very difficult
time
um
I
here it is now
since 2008 so much time has passed
yet as I sit here and talk to you I am
thanks
I'm still very deeply involved in
Afghanistan and I'm still what I'm
trying to do now at my age
how old do you know I'm in my 70s I'm
77. you're 77.
yeah
uh I still run I still take time I've
had heart operation
um which one doctors said was a result
of the stress
or implied the doctor said I don't tell
you exactly
or maybe they don't know
um yeah I've had open heart surgery I've
had I still I run to the degree that I
can run train
um
and
I'm still involved very much very much
in Afghanistan
contact with the economies
um
none of which I've asked for everything
has come to me it's as if it's a
combination of being led or it's
it's
culmination being Latin because that's
oh I want to do this no
no I do other things but Afghanistan is
still very much a part of my life and
I'm taking enormous risks I do I take
risk now
um but I try not to be foolish
I was really really
really playing with fire the last time
but I thought I could do it because
every time the Taliban kept a word until
they didn't and I feel I was betrayed by
people around me and people behind them
um
I don't for one minute support the
Taliban
no not at all but I also don't I also
realize that
the United States and Saudi Arabia and
Pakistan in our on our world in our
desire America's desire
to
move the war against communism from from
Vietnam to Afghanistan which we did
after the last American Soldier was
killed it was a Marine in 1973 and we
with Pakistan and Saudi Arabia
um
began to
and and
we began to and this is borne out in in
books written by American officials
we began to use the mujahideen
to lure the Soviet Union into
Afghanistan to pay them back for for
helping
the North Vietnamese and the Viet Cong
against us in Vietnam in our war against
in our Crusade against communism
and that
in that by
do and I became very much involved in
that very much involved in that in the
19th after I came back I was involved
with with the government
who was the head of the peace talks and
I created
he was Far More in charge than I but
they used my name and my because of my
publicity in the New York Times and
that's the only first person in
Afghanistan
um
to create
a
what was called friends of Afghanistan
it was run by the overseeing by National
Security Council in the state department
all in our war against communism
this is during the Reagan Administration
and I was involved in that and I was
there I did it to help the women and
children and because I was also asked
very very much
to by the by the mujahideen to do
something to shoot down the Soviet
helicopters and so I wrote an op-ed
piece in the New York Times precisely
doing that to asking you calling on the
U.S to do that knowing full well it was
going to cause more more Soviet bombers
and more Soviet troops in Afghanistan
but I felt an obligation to the people I
became part of that
part of that effort
and I I wanted to move away from that
and when I I left all of that and I
worked for National Geographic and they
sent me a far away far away places and
fantastic exploration projects
and I pushed it in every single one of
those projects
find the source of Amazon to go to the
find the source of the brahmaputra in
Western Tibet uh pushing everything
never finding anything that's satisfied
or
what I felt in Afghanistan I kept
looking for it I needed more I needed
more
it wasn't until I ended up fighting my
own War
in that prison
with the Taliban there was a sense of
of
survival of accomplishment but still it
goes on
that I that what I'm doing today is
still very and I'm taking risks today
yeah I am
you're going to Afghanistan in a week
uh two weeks I think
it's too bad I'm waiting for the phone
call
um
and before I don't want to take us off
topic but I've heard so many people
Lauren uh my friend Lauren included
say such wonderful things about
Afghanistan
oh yes oh yes there's something about
Africa and soldiers will tell you this
and you know American Service people uh
men and women
Marines uh Air Force people they'll tell
you how uh there's a warmth and there's
this sense of Afghans I've never seen it
anywhere how welcoming they are
um no other country have I ever been in
uh have people invited me into their
home constantly and giving
they'll give you the if they don't have
enough food for themselves they'll give
you what they have they'll give you what
they have there's a sense of of
of warmth and Hospitality that is that
is marvelous part of it is very much of
its is part of it's called mel-mastia in
in Pashto it's part of their ancient
culture
and it was it was the the romance of
course of of camel Caravans and
um as if it's the Middle Ages in some
ways and the warmth and hospitality and
generosity of those people that Drew so
many if you will
for black I'm a better word hippies to
Afghanistan in the 1980s uh or in the
70s excuse me
um and
there's so many people who love
Afghanistan it's it's almost unique in
the world now it's now because of the
arabization of the war it's a much more
violent place it's a much more difficult
place and that's why the Taliban we have
a Taliban problem
uh particularly as regards to girls and
that's just one reason why I'm I'm going
back because it's hostage work but also
the
yeah they become far more uh without
becoming getting into too deeply into
this uh wahhabism which is the very the
most uh rigid radical form of Islam
which comes from Saudi Arabia which
until recently maybe a woman could not
even drive and they had to be covered
all of that which was came with Al Qaeda
what became Al Qaeda is all the
arabization of Afghanistan and it is has
changed it completely it's completely
destroyed culture and it has to I don't
know how they're going to change and but
that good part is
still there it's it's it's the
some very romantic wonderful lovely
fascinating
place but
it shouldn't spend your life it's a what
did Lawrence of Arabia say about his
book it's a Yahoo existence who exists
for others so I don't it's not for
others you do it for yourself everything
ultimately you do it because of yourself
why am I going there why are you doing
what you do you do it for what it gives
you
all that you're doing and how
uh compassionate you are and how you're
helping others and
the joy that you have that we've talked
about the happiness
um
yeah I grew up I remember
one final thing is
when I was a boy I used to take our
horse a horse and I'd go down along the
river one and we had to along the
Columbia River and I would ride as fast
as I could and I always wanted it was a
part of me going up in the Northwest and
came from my father
um who like he said I always when you
talk to an Indian a lot of Indian
they're Indian tribes around us
um
always ask the name of this tribe
they're proud of their tribe
and I remember when I lived with the
economies with jalala Dean
in
there's a part of me that wanted to be
an Indian not a cowboy as a boy
she's very much a part of this and I
remember when it took me one day where
they took me way up into the mountains
to an arms cache
and he and I raced horses back
and I remember looking over at him this
mujahideen Commander
beard Turman Kalashnikov
we were racing as fast as we could
across the Plains and it was everything
I dreamed about as a boy
I wanted to be an Indian and ride with
the sense of freedom
that's what it gave me and I felt that
with with the economies who are an
extremely powerful lethal Johannes group
I realized that
but yeah there's a warmth there that I
loved and it goes back to my childhood
reading like an Indian across the plains
no one has ever brought that out good
job thanks
Jerry
what an incredible thing you've been
through
thank you so much for sharing your story
thank you Mark
I would have done it without
I've done this
like this without you
good luck in Afghanistan
maybe I'll see you there so okay you
might